Soixante-dix pages ?!
Non,
c’est pas possible !
Tu te rends compte,
Haristote :
soixante-dix pages !
Soixante-dix pages,
c’est la taille de l’introduction
du cours de culture générale
sur le thème des concours
d’un élève de Prépa HEC
qui m’a écrit.
Rendez-vous bien compte :
soixante-dix pages,
c’est UNIQUEMENT
pour l’introduction !
Du coup,
le cours complet,
ça va être combien de pages ?
Cinq-cent ?
Six-cent ?
Non mais
ça va.
Six-cents pages,
il faut combien de temps,
pour les apprendre ?
Six-cents ans ?
Oui mais d’ici là,
on saura télécharger l’information
DIRECTEMENT
dans le cerveau.
ET SI
je vous disais
que vous pouvez vous en sortir
BIEN MIEUX
qu’avec le cours de votre prof
AVEC SEULEMENT
10 PAGES ?
Qu’est-ce que c’est,
la méthode des paragraphes ?
C’est très simple.
Il s’agit de créer un stock de paragraphes
que vous pourrez FACILEMENT
utiliser et réutiliser
dans TOUTES
vos dissertations
sur le thème de l’année.
C’est quoi,
les avantages de cette méthode ?
Vous n’avez PLUS BESOIN
d’apprendre le cours.
de trouver des arguments
ni des références.
Et enfin,
vous n’avez PLUS BESOIN
de rédiger le développement
de vos dissertations
— puisqu’il vous suffit de recopier
les paragraphes que vous avez
préparés.
Résultat ?
L’épreuve de dissertation est
BIEN PLUS FACILE,
vous êtes moins stressés.
Grâce à vos paragraphes,
vos arguments,
vos références
et votre style sont
BIEN MEILLEURS ;
donc vos notes DÉCOLLENT.
Et je n’invente pas,
parce que
depuis que j’ai créé
et popularisé cette méthode
avec mon manuel
cinquante paragraphes « tout cuits »
— c’était en 2016 —
eh bien depuis 2016,
j’ai reçu DES CENTAINES
de témoignages
d’élèves de Prépa HEC,
qui m’ont dit
qu’ils avaient gagné
BEAUCOUP DE POINTS
et BEAUCOUP DE TEMPS
grâce à ma méthode des paragraphes.
J’ai reçu TELLEMENT
de témoignages
que cette année il m’a fallu
une journée ENTIÈRE
pour les trier.
En fait,
je dois être honnête avec vous :
JE NE PENSAIS PAS
que cette méthode marcherait
AUSSI BIEN.
La vérité,
c’est que quand des élèves me disent
qu’ils décrochent DIX-HUIT
à la dissertation de culture générale
du concours d’HEC
en ayant travaillé le thème avec ma méthode
pendant seulement
UNE SEMAINE
DE TOUTE L’ANNÉE
— la vérité,
c’est que quand ils me disent ça,
je suis un peu gêné.
Mais bon,
quand j’apprends
que des profs font
des introductions de SOIXANTE-DIX PAGES
sur le thème,
la gêne disparaît.
Bref,
la méthode des paragraphes,
ça marche très bien,
et je vais vous expliquer
DANS LE DÉTAIL
comment MOI
je m’en sers
dans cette vidéo.
Si vous voulez voir
à quoi ressemble
un stock de paragraphes,
je vous laisse regarder
mes cinquante paragraphes « tout cuits »
sur le thème du désir,
que j’ai rédigés en 2019.
Vous pouvez accéder
à mon fichier Google Docs
soit en cliquant
sur le lien qui s’affiche maintenant
en haut à droite,
soit en cliquant
sur celui qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Jetez-y un coup d’œil
maintenant si vous voulez,
mais revenez bien à cette vidéo
et regardez-la
JUSQU’AU BOUT.
Écoutez-moi ATTENTIVEMENT